if you go too close to that magnet then
it's just going to wipe the tape
if you
don't find quantum mechanics incredibly
unsettling and disturbing you don't
understand it
oh my gosh
we're actually positioned like this and
as a result there are more collisions on
this side
yeah there's this very strange thing
about mercury
actually they have
tails that do a kind of helical motion
so all the blue photons get scattered
and then the yellow and then the green
this is a very hand waving and waving
description so one symbol that's very
important to me is the symbol j
and i'll sprinkle a bit on
oh that's probably too much
wow
my gosh this has to be one of the
coolest things i've ever seen i
completely didn't think we were going to
be able to see it like that
if i get them too close they attract
both that's so strongly so these are the
five basic units
they're cool um i like black holes
wow did you see that
good grief
that's about the height he's ever got
wow
and again it's a pretty stable system
and you shake this about and you try and
mix it up
you